[Musique]
la petite reine à ces petits princes 26
enfants de 8 à 11 ans qui en six jours
vont avaler en vtt 120 km deux mille
mètres de dénivelé de bibracte alésia
entre coups de pédales coûte pour
enfants etc ou demain voici leur
histoire
[Musique]
les jours filent les paysages forestiers
du morvan au céder la place au bocage de
l'eau soir pas ça qui va vous avez pu
nous retrouvons le groupe qui vit
l'avant dernière étape de son période
24km programme bien vallonné voit le
petit bout de plats du dessus de la côte
vous êtes des champions pour encadrer
sécurisé et encourager les élèves des
parents aux pédales à leurs côtés ils
ont posé une semaine de congé
convaincu de vivre une aventure
collective hors du commun
ça permet aussi de couper un petit peu
avec avec le quotidien puisqu'on est
carrément hors du temps toute la journée
on traverse des paysages magnifiques là
c'est très agréable avec les enfants
puisque c'est des moments qu'on partage
juste avec eux aussi et on n'est pas
accaparé par les problèmes personnels
les problèmes professionnels c'est très
agréable on découvre qu'ils sont un peu
plus autonome qu'à la maison en fait il
des vacances et voilà il sort il se gère
tout seul on les maternelles - les fans
de l'autonomie sinon ça ça donne ça fait
grandir
fini le silence appliquée du premier
jour à vélo désormais on sourit on se
taquine les élèves ont beaucoup
progressé sur l'anticipation des
trajectoires et des changements de
vitesse
je vous regarde loin si on regarde
regardez moi là je regarde par terre tu
vas les parterres regarder loin devant
rick nash tout de suite ça monte ça
montre les cliniques dans ces passages
comme ça où il ya justement un petit peu
de détective
on passe au dessus sur une passerelle au
dessus de l'eau et bien souvent quand il
ya un gros d'affectif ça casse un petit
peu tous les apprentissages et puis donc
on attend entre guillemets à régresser
donc on les rassure et on les rappelle
les petits trucs qui leur permettent
justement de aller plus loin
une pente raide et revoilà l'occasion
pour le jean marc et christian de
travailler sur la prise de risque et
donc sur la confiance en soi de leurs
petits protégés ou peu plus vite mais
parce que tu vas bloqué sur les cailloux
sinon certains chute encore mais
découvre aussi que le plus important
c'est de se relever
ça fait trois fois que je tombe sur le
même genou trois fois en descente c'est
c'est chaud patate pour moi des fois sur
les chemins il ya des ornières et du
coup bah quand tourmente son milieu bas
ça on tombe par terre
à chacun son enjeu ne plus tomber pour
les uns assurer le ravitaillement du
groupe
pour karen on va sortir sur la route ici
c'est bon pourquoi ouais c'est bon en
fait faut que tu fasses par là ok c'est
vrai que les enfants et les parents
accompagnateurs
e.on l'effort physique nous on est plus
sur l'effort à réfléchir quelques hôtes
il faut prendre être là au bon moment
il ya des points stratégiques pour
réparer les vélos s'il le faut pour
donner à boire aux enfants à manger faut
pas se tromper de route et faut être
tenté malgré le stress cette maman comme
tous les autres adultes est heureuse de
participer à ce projet à cette grande
bouffée d'oxygène en pleine nature qui
arrive à point nommé pour les enfants
après une année et demie sous l'ère
covin
fin d'étape les enfants peuvent enfin
souffler pas les organisateurs chaque
soir christian et jean marc contrôler et
réparer les vélos main dans la main ces
deux là se connaissent depuis près de 40
ans depuis leur formation d'instituteurs
le bibracte alésia se nourrit de leur
amitié
c'est un moment très fort nous
relationnel aussi bien avec les bien sûr
avec les élèves et puis les
accompagnateurs rapide mais qui équipe
une équipe qui organise pour la 29e fois
cette randonnée en vtt et qui sait à
quel point la journée du lendemain
la dernière de laventure sera riche en
émotions
[Musique]